a minha história começa uma sessão de
terapia
imagino que vocês não devem achar muito
original não ficar pra falar de sessão
de terapia
mas espero que vocês gostem da história
bem interessante
ela começa a mais ou menos dez anos
atrás
sete anos atrás eram março muito quente
desses marços super quente tem
importante é que o final do verão
o paciente então chegou à seleção e me
contou das férias que ele tinha tido era
a primeira sessão depois das férias dele
e da minha até a meio da sessão ele me
contou de pessoas que ele conheceu de
lugares bacanas que ele conheceu lá pelo
meio da sessão ele tirou o celular e
começou a mostrar fotos dos lugares e
das pessoas que tinham conhecido na
época fiquei horrorizado
que estranho porque na minha formação
como psiquiatra como terapeuta
a gente aprende que a palavra importante
a cura apenas palavras
a palavra que simboliza a foto celular
era uma coisa absolutamente concreta bom
algum tempo se passou dez a 15 anos e
hoje
hoje os pacientes mostra muito mais do
que fotos né
o paciente está em celulares e lêem
textos do ates contam que conheceram
pessoas pelo facebook
o ponto de encontro secreto pelo
schiller trazem áudios em que nos mostra
para nós ouvimos juntos
o mundo mudou de fato o mundo mudou mas
o mundo está falando
acho importante fazer um parêntese
porque está falando do mundo da inclusão
social nesse site aqui você pode ver os
lugares do mundo incluídos pela internet
basicamente hemisfério norte
existem muitos pontos obscuros na em que
nós estamos
existe de fato 50 por cento da população
mundial que não têm acesso a computador
e à internet
existe um fosso digital entre nós
apesar disso eu quero deixar claro que
vou falar neste momento é a partir de
agora as pessoas que são incluídas no
mundo digital
mas eu rendo minha homenagem aqui
e ainda não estão nas redes sociais elas
provocarão mudanças profundas na forma
como a gente interage e na forma como se
comunica com os outros
o facebook foi criado em 2004 e ele tem
dois bilhões de pessoas usuárias do
facebook é interessante que ele tem
crescido especialmente em países
subdesenvolvidos por exemplo bangkok na
tailândia é hoje a capital do facebook
ela tem 25 milhões de usuários em bancoc
do facebook
a pergunta que fica para nós é com a
associação que tem entre esse aumento
crescente do nosso acesso às redes
sociais e à nossa saúde mental
os resultados das pesquisas são
absolutamente contraditória
provavelmente por diferenças
metodológicas e outros problemas
pelo menos três conclusões mais ou menos
se pode chegar até esse momento existe
uma associação entre o uso excessivo das
redes sociais e sintomas depressivos
uma outra sensação das redes sociais com
a autoestima e finalmente uma sensação
de dependência com as redes sociais é
essa falar da depressão
os sintomas depressivos eles podem
acontecer em pessoas que utilizam muito
as redes sociais especialmente tristeza
e solidão são muitos sentidos por
pessoas que se utilizam muito as redes
sociais
mas por outro lado pessoas que fazem a
comunicação online por exemplo o
whatsapp familiares amigos muito íntimos
elas se sentem menos sós ao contrário
elas se sentem menos tristes
acho que esse é um exemplo dos efeitos
benéficos das redes sociais com as
pessoas em relação à autoestima
autoestima elemento absolutamente
importante fundamental o desenvolvimento
e de manutenção da nossa saúde mental
parece aquelas pessoas com autoestima
diminuída fazem muito mais uso das redes
sociais também principalmente costuma
postar conteúdos de autopromoção
e pensando em autopromoção tem um estudo
muito interessante publicado
recentemente com duas mil moças meninas
de 16 a 25 anos na inglaterra
olha que interessante elas permanecem
cinco horas por semana envolvidas nos
seus apps
isso dá uma média de 48 horas e 48
minutos por dia envolvidos em atividades
um self que um dado interessante a cada
7 céu fiz o que elas pensam em postar
elas escolhem apenas um self perfeito
então é muito tempo né na autopromoção
gente colocar aí no instagram hash tags
elfes nós vamos ter hoje em dia 275
milhões de imagens são self não é um
auto retrato da filha acaba não é é
interessante pensar nessas etapas
observarem todos estão com o lado
esquerdo da face em fevereiro deste ano
foi publicado um artigo sobre isso
um artigo que pesquisa qual lado das
pessoas da face é mais postado como self
incrível qual é o resultado a face
esquerda tanto no espelho na média entre
o espelho e o self normal
a faixa esquerda é mais postado
talvez seja uma teoria meio espúrio algo
meio bizarro e curioso mas talvez seja
isso talvez esteja iniciando na questão
do conhecimento sobre as redes sociais
o terceiro aspecto eu queria falar com
vocês é sobre as dependências
dependência às redes sociais
é muita gente poder ver essa questão
dentro de um contínuo onde pessoas fazem
uso muito adequado das redes sociais e
outras são dependentes e independentes
porque tem greve tem fissura dependente
porque tem abstinência dependente porque
têm recaídas
como alguém que usa nicotina álcool e
drogas é bastante importante que na
realidade só uma minoria das pessoas que
acessam as redes sociais são
independentes mas isso dá um
interessante em torno de 6% da população
mundial
uma dependência ou smartphone ou os
games ou as redes sociais
essa dependência coloca as pessoas
muitas vezes em situações de risco
pessoas correm risco ao dirigir o carro
e acessar suas redes sociais
outras situações também são muito
estranho quando as pessoas acessam as
redes sociais como é que avalia essa
dependência pesquisadoras da noruega
fizeram uma um instrumento
especificamente para avaliar a
dependência o facebook
esse instrumento tem 18 itens que é mais
importante e um item específico desse
instrumento porque ele avalia a
qualidade do sono resultante do acesso
às redes sociais especialmente o
facebook
a gente sabe que pessoas dependentes do
facebook passam noites em claro isso tem
um impacto fundamental sobre a saúde
mental
a pergunta que se faça isso é um
diagnóstico psiquiátrico não segundo as
idéias dsm-5 a adição à dependência às
redes sociais e à dependência internet
ainda não é um diagnóstico psiquiátrico
o diagnóstico sindicato realizado no dsm
5 é o diagnóstico de dependência aos
games
agora a gente tem que pensar em fatores
de riscos
qual é a população que tem mais risco de
se tornar dependente das redes sociais
mulheres jovens pessoas com os controle
de impulsos introvertidos perfeccionista
com baixa autoestima e aquelas pessoas
com necessidade de aprovação
agora quando se fala em cuidados de
saúde termos do que está conversando
aqui hoje é importante pensar assim que
não está dizendo que as pessoas devem
usar ou são proibidas de usar as redes
sociais
a questão que está falando é de uso mais
comedido das redes sociais e quais são
as perspectivas sobre a gente entender
melhor essa relação entre redes sociais
e saúde mental
as perspectivas e respeito a um melhor
ordenamento de estudos
todos os estudos que se conhece até
agora são estudos de associação por
exemplo eu falei para vocês que as
pessoas que têm mais acesso às redes
sociais elas têm mais
thomas depressivos isso é uma associação
isto não é uma causa e efeito não
significa que as pessoas que fazem mais
as redes sociais têm mais depressão para
fazer estudos de causa e efeito a gente
tem que acompanhar as pessoas por um
longo tempo
a maioria dos estudos são feitos com
pessoas normais
nós precisamos saber de estudos com
pessoas com transtornos psiquiátricos
por exemplo de pressão tensão de polar e
outros
os estudos são feitos de uma forma em
que generaliza nas redes sociais
as redes sociais são muito diferentes o
instagram facebook o ats
a ideia é que se necessita fazer estudos
muito específicos para cada rede social
provavelmente quem está falando então é
de uma educação para os novos usuários e
isso passa pelas escolas passa pelos
fundamental passa pelos professores e
passa especialmente pelos pais no brasil
gente no brasil envolveu muito sério
o brasil é um dos países que as crianças
acesso à internet mais precocemente aos
nove anos de idade
na média que elas ficam mais vulneráveis
vulneráveis a situações de exposição
automutilação por exemplo a baleia azul
elas ficam mais vulneráveis a qual o
comportamento fitness que pode originar
transtornos alimentares como bulimia e
anorexia elas ficam mais vulneráveis ao
cyber bullying que se espera o que
precisa fazer
nós precisamos encurtar as pontes entre
as gerações entre os nativos digitais
que hoje tem menos de 30 anos e nós os
imigrantes digitais
é muito importante que se feche esse
diálogo que esse diálogo seja mais
próximo
para isso a gente tem que estimular o
diálogo absolutamente aberto honesto e
genuinamente interessado na tecnologia
genuinamente interessado em saber como é
que o game funciona como é que a rede
social funciona
olha que interessante atualmente 60% das
crianças que têm dois a cinco anos têm
capacidade de jogar games
capacidade de jogar games em
computadores 20% delas conseguem jogar
em aplicativos smartphone só 11% da
capacidade já tá os seus sapatos que
mundo é esse o mundo mudou
o do absolutamente mudou em privacidade
nas redes sociais os tornaram menos
privados
por outro lado a gente tem muito mais
transparência
o substantivo mudou o que era a privação
quer privacidade se tornou transparência
eu vou terminar lembrando a história eu
comecei cantando para vocês eram março
verão quente em porto alegre que estava
em uma sessão de terapia atendendo um
paciente me trouxe fotografia e eu
fiquei absolutamente abismado
que coisa né quanta coisa passou hoje o
que se sabe é bem interessante é que as
redes sociais se por um lado tem
associação com sintomas depressivos com
baixa autoestima e com dependência elas
também estão proporcionando as pessoas
têm muita dificuldade de interagir uma
possibilidade muito diferente de
interagir entende poder pensar de um
lado e de outro fazer o equilíbrio tem
que ser despido de preconceitos olhar as
redes sociais de uma outra forma uma
visão muito menos alarmista e muito
menos reducionista e esperando que as
futuras pesquisas possam nos dar luzes
para a gente entender melhor essa
relação entre saúde mental e redes
sociais
obrigado
[Aplausos]